c'est durant cette période le seul moyen
le seul moyen d'agir efficacement le
confinement ne peut pas être le moyen
premier de lutte contre le virus
le constat est sans appel et les viandes
de l'envoyé spécial de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
oco vite 19 les confinements n'ont
qu'une seule conséquence que vous ne
devez jamais minimiser c'est de rendre
les pauvres beaucoup plus pauvres
bridgestone à béthune chapelle darblay à
grand-couronne bénéteau à noirmoutier
schneider electric
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
les plans sociaux se succèdent 32 sites
au total et près de 5000 salariés sur le
carreau
et si la fortune des calculs 2200
milliardaire dont le monde a progressé
de 27 % pendant le confinement et les
classes moyennes mais aussi les plus
précaires les cdd ou encore les
étudiants eux ont subi les conséquences
de plein fouet une vague de pauvreté
s'abat sur le pays et la situation s'est
aggravée depuis le confinement
malgré cela la réaction des pouvoirs
publics est très faible
elle s'apparente même un déni de réalité
l exécutif semble vouloir à tout prix
éviter en confinement général mais il
pourrait être tenté par les solutions de
confinement localisés dont l'espace ou
dans le temps nous avons une stratégie
claire qui consiste à avoir une riposte
graduée et territorialisée à la crise
nous avons pris les décisions qui
s'imposaient nous continuons de le
prendre elles sont déclinées
territorialement
parce que c'est comme ça qu'il faut
faire du côté des scientifiques on mails
les mêmes doutes quant à la solution du
confinement
le british medical journal publiait le 7
octobre dernier un article mentionnant
la déclaration du great barrington une
initiative de plusieurs sommités
mondiales de la recherche qui appelait à
une stratégie de protection ciblé des
personnes à risque plutôt que le
confinement
les personnes âgées et en mille fois
plus susceptibles de mourir de lakovic
19 que les personnes plus jeunes une
approche stratifié parages pourrait
permettre de concentrer les ressources
sur les patients plus âgés et à haut
risque tout en permettant à des
personnes plus jeunes et en meilleure
santé d'aller à l'école et
de garder les entreprises ouvertes à ce
jour les confinements ont de manière
générale montré une capacité certaine à
ralentir l'épidémie mais elles n'ont pas
empêché le rebond de cette dernière en
france une fois l'été passé
de plus selon plusieurs scientifiques le
remède serait pire que le mal il est
évident que les conséquences sociales
économiques sont sans aucune comparaison
avec le problème sanitaire ce qui semble
être en cause dans l'incapacité des pays
européens à l'été contre le virus c'est
l'affaiblissement de nos systèmes de
santé à l'exception de l'allemagne
plutôt qu une malchance ou une fatalité
une hypothèse confirmée par cette
récente étude du lancet qui a comparé
les mesures prises en asie et en europe
lors de la première vague en europe
plus d'une décennie de mesures
d'austérité ont considérablement
affaibli les systèmes de santé et la
protection sociale
en revanche des épidémies majeures ont
poussé de nombreux pays asiatiques à
investir dans la construction
d'infrastructures bien équipé pour faire
face à la prochaine épidémie avec plus
de moyens plus de personnel et plus de
lits de réanimation nous aurions sans
doute pu éviter le confinement ce n'est
pas le choix qui a été fait par nos
dirigeants est la question aujourd'hui
alors que tous les indicateurs sont au
rouge est de savoir si l'état a
véritablement tirer les leçons de la
première vague